[Música]
buenas tardes cuando pensamos en costa
rica es casi imposible no pensar en
nuestras playas en nuestras montañas y
en esa riqueza natural
que nos distingue porque para muchas
personas alrededor del mundo costa rica
es un símbolo de protección del medio
ambiente pero qué pasó en el 2016 uno de
mis socios juan carlos vio un documental
un documental que nos cambió la vida un
documental en donde cuesta rica era la
protagonista la protagonista de uno de
los problemas más grandes a nivel
mundial de aleteo de tiburones dado eso
empezamos a investigar y empezamos a
trabajar para ver qué podíamos hacer
para corregir esa mala imagen que nos
estaban dando y conforme más
investigamos nos dábamos cuenta de más
problemas en donde por ejemplo el 75% de
las especies marinas hoy en día están
siendo totalmente explotadas
sobreexplotadas o en peligro extensión y
lo más doloroso de todo esto es que
muchos gobiernos alrededor del mundo por
no decir que todos al no tener
mecanismos de control adecuado terminan
financiando y subsidiando gran parte de
las actividades
y legales e irresponsables que suceden
en los océanos con miles de millones de
dólares
año tras año también nos dimos cuenta
que el 50 por ciento o más del 50 por
ciento mejor dicho de lo que se extrae
del mar se extrae con embarcaciones como
la que están viendo en esa imagen
embarcaciones totalmente artesanales
entonces empezamos a trabajar con
pescadores artesanales
[Música]
ha sido increíble poder ver esos
amaneceres y esos atardeceres pero no
todo es tan bonito un día por ejemplo
luego de 12 horas en altamar
llevando son todos jugados y con el
estómago totalmente revuelto del
movimiento de la embarcación
ese día después de esos 12 horas solo
pescamos 6 kilos 6 kilos de pescado y
ocupamos pescar al menos 18 para cubrir
los gastos del hielo la carnada la
gasolina y todo lo que involucra salir a
pescar y días como estos son los que
nuestros pescadores viven más seguido de
lo que uno se imagina
y además de eso ese pescado que están
viendo y ese pargo que a veces compramos
un kilo en un supermercado a trece mil
colones a ellos se los compran a veces a
900 colones si a 900 colones
definitivamente eso es un problema
y transformar ese problema en una
solución o en una oportunidad no es nada
fácil todo lo contrario hemos tenido
mucho miedo hemos cometido muchos
errores hemos tenido momentos de
incertidumbre por mucho tiempo aquí en
costa rica
que creía en lo que estábamos haciendo
entonces tuvimos que salir buscar
organizaciones fuera de costa rica
alemania francia estados unidos
inglaterra poco a poco nos empezaron a
validar que lo que estábamos haciendo
realmente tenía sentido y más
recientemente noruega uno de los países
más exportadores de peces que por ende
es uno de los países más desarrollados
en el sector pesquero nos han dado un
apoyo grandísimo un apoyo que inclusive
se convirtió en inversión y ahora
tenemos un capital de inversión no luego
dentro de nuestra empresa en este camino
nos hemos dado cuenta que si queremos
garantizar la pesca responsable y
sostenible tenemos que educar y
sensibilizar a nuestros pescadores nos
hemos dado cuenta que si queremos tener
un producto de calidad
inocuo tenemos que invertir en
infraestructura para ellos y nos hemos
dado cuenta también que si queremos
garantizar de que llegue un producto
fresco a nuestros platos tenemos que
apoyarnos de la tecnología y a pesar de
que estamos trabajando en estos
necesarios quiero hacer un énfasis en la
tecnología eso es por ejemplo son
algunas de las soluciones que hemos
venido desarrollando en los últimos años
son soluciones que nos permiten obtener
una gran cantidad de información que más
adelante les voy a contar pero vamos a
hacer un énfasis en esta es una balanza
inteligente una balanza en donde cuando
uno le pone un pescado automáticamente
se empieza a producir procesar una serie
información que pescado es cuánto pesa y
eso se empieza a vincular con otra serie
de tecnologías en inteligencia
artificial red neuronales machine
learning internet de las cosas
procesamiento imágenes blogs singh y
demás para que al final podamos generar
un código un código que cuando nos
cuando nosotros compremos ese producto
en el supermercado no es nos despliegue
toda la información inclusive de quien
pescó ese pescado
en qué momento tiene un filet yo y toda
la información que se puedan imaginar
todo eso sucede en cuestión de un
segundo
y junto con las otras soluciones al
final lo que logramos recopilar son una
serie de variables que nos permiten
saber qué cómo dónde cuándo y quién pues
con pescado pero también nos permite
identificar
y se respetaron las áreas marinas
protegidas a la hora de la pesca nos
permite identificar qué tipo de arte
pesca se utilizó también podemos
recuperar un montón de información
biológica que nos permita tomar más y
mejores decisiones todas esas variables
y esas tecnologías son los que creemos
que nos van a ayudar para dos cosas y ya
nos ya nos están ayudando a eso por un
lado contribuir a la conservación de
nuestros mares de nuestros océanos pero
por otro lado nos permite aumentar el
valor a la actividad pesquera para que
estos pescadores empiecen a ganar como
se debe para que se vean menos menos
tentados a cometer una mala decisión con
tal de dar alimento a sus familias y
ustedes se preguntarán quién paga por
esto bueno el hecho es que hicimos una
empresa que invierte en todo lo que sea
necesario para que una comunidad
pesquera pueda tener una buena
sensibilización conciencia
infraestructura y tecnologías de punta
y nosotros lo que hacemos es conectarlo
con canales que les permita
generar valor tener una mejor calidad de
vida
y sobre ese valor adicional que le
generamos que puede ser de hasta un 600
por ciento más inclusive más nosotros
dejamos una comisión una comisión que
nos permite seguir creciendo impactando
a otras comunidades alrededor de costa
rica y el mundo hoy que es el día
mundial de los océanos yo no les quiero
contar lo que es comercio justo no les
quiero contar lo que es una u otra
tecnología yo lo que quiero que se
lleven es
que nuestro mares y nuestros océanos
están en peligro
y más allá del peligro es que no nos
estamos preocupando lo suficiente
ocupamos a más personas a más
organizaciones a más gobiernos
trabajando de la mano trabajando en
equipo porque ahí depende de que
sobrevivamos o no mi nombre es brian a
barbour y junto con un grupo de
ingenieros artistas diseñadores estamos
haciendo hasta lo imposible por generar
un impacto en este mundo estamos
esforzándonos al máximo para demostrar
de que si se puede pero más allá de eso
mi mensaje es que ustedes hoy se
inspiren para que estén aquí entre dos o
tres años contándonos sus historias de
mostrándole al mundo de que si uno
quiere se puede no acepten un nuevo por
respuesta' esfuercen al máximo por hacer
un cambio que el mundo lo necesita
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]